♪ ♪
>> Sean: JUST SAT DOWN WITH
VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE IN
NEW YORK TO DISCUSS ALL THE
CONTROVERSY WITH THE SO-CALLED
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
WE TALKED A LOT ABOUT IT.
ALSO ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HERE'S WHAT HE HAD TO SAY.
>> Vice President Pence: I
>> Vice President Pence: E
>> Vice President Pence: L
>> Vice President Pence: T
>> Vice President Pence: S
>> Vice President Pence: F
>> Vice President Pence: L
>> Vice President Pence: H
>> Vice President Pence: S
>> Vice President Pence: U
>> Vice President Pence: R
>> Vice President Pence: I
>> Vice President Pence: E
THING.
IT'S LIKE MANNA FROM HEAVEN.
WE ARE NOW DISCOVERING THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER, IT WAS NOT
FIRST-HAND KNOWLEDGE.
EVEN THE MEDIA IS NOW REPORTING
IN SOME PLACES THAT THERE WAS NO
QUID PRO QUO.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US?
>> Vice President Pence: HERE
WE GO AGAIN.
THE WORST MEDIA.
TAKES ONE REPORT, RUNS WITH IT.
DEMOCRATS ON CAPITOL HILL
IMMEDIATELY START TO DENOUNCE
THE PRESIDENT BEFORE ANYBODY HAS
THE FACTS.
BUT THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN VERY
CLEAR ON THIS.
HE MADE A CONGRATULATORY CALL TO
PRESIDENT ZELINSKI, WHICH WAS A
LANDSLIDE ELECTION.
THE PRESIDENT SPOKE TO HIM ABOUT
OUR CONCERN, INVESTING HUNDREDS
AND MILLIONS OF
AMERICAN DOLLARS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP MADE IT CLEAR
THAT WE'VE GOT TO SEE REFORMS.
WE'VE GOT TO SEE HONESTY IN
GOVERNMENT.
HIS CONGRATULATORY CALL WAS ALL
ABOUT THAT.
HE MENTIONED VICE PRESIDENT
BIDEN AND HIS SON AND THE
CONTEXT OF US WANTING TO SEE
HONEST GOVERNMENT.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THE AMERICAN
TAXPAYER WOULD EXPECT.
SEE WHEN HERE YOU HAVE,
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN BRAGGING ON
TAPE, "YOU ARE NOT GETTING
$1 MILLION.
YOU EITHER FIRE THE PROSECUTOR.
WHY WOULD THE VICE PRESIDENT
WANT TO FIRE HIM?
WHY WOULD A VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES AMERICA WANT A
UKRAINIAN PROSECUTOR FIRED?
WHAT CONCEIVABLE REASON WOULD
THAT BE?
>> Vice President Pence: IT'S
REALLY REMARKABLE.
EVERYTHING THAT THE MEDIA WANTS
TO ASSUME OF HOW THE PRESIDENT'S
PHONE CALL IN JULY WENT.
HE ADMITTED TO, ON CAMERA, IN
JANUARY 2018, HE SAID THAT WHEN
HE WAS VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, HE HAD A QUID PRO
QUO.
HE  HE SAID TO UKRAINIAN OFFICIA
HE  HE SAID TO UKRAINIAN OFFICIS
HE  HE SAID TO UKRAINIAN OFFICI,
YOU WILL NOT GET AMERICAN AID
UNLESS YOU FIRE A PROSECUTOR.
>> Sean: HE'S MAKING A LOT OF
MONEY.
APPARENTLY WITH NO BACKGROUND.
>> Vice President Pence: OF
THE PEOPLE DESERVE TO KNOW.
TO HAVE A VICE PRESIDENT
THREATENING, THAT'S THE QUID PRO
QUO.
AS THE PRESIDENT SAID IN HIS
CONVERSATION THAT EVERYONE IS
VERY INTERESTED IN NOW, HIS
CONVERSATION WITH
PRESIDENT ZELINSKI, THAT HE
SPOKE ABOUT CONGRATULATIONS.
HE SPOKE ABOUT OUR SUPPORT FOR
THE UKRAINE.
HE SPOKE ABOUT OUR CONCERN ABOUT
CORRUPTION.
BUT THERE WAS NO QUID PRO QUO.
IF PEOPLE WANT TO SEE A QUID PRO
QUO, THEY JUST WANT TO SEE THE
TAPE OF PRESIDENT BIDEN.
OVER $1 BILLION.
>> Sean: I WOULD SAY
BLACKMAIL.
AM I WRONG ON THAT?
>> Vice President Pence: SEAN,
I CAN TELL YOU, THIS IS A
COUNTRY THAT WAS OVERRUN BY
RUSSIA.
IT'S A COUNTRY THAT IS STILL AT
WAR.
THEY STILL HAVE, WE BELIEVE,
RUSSIAN ELEMENTS THERE.
THEY ARE TRYING TO LITERALLY
TEAR THE UKRAINE APART.
FOR VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN, WHO
REFUSED TO GIVE MILITARY AID TO
UKRAINE, TO THREATEN WHAT
REMAINED OF THAT AID UNLESS THEY
RESPONDED TO HIS DEMANDS ABOUT
FIRING A PROSECUTOR, WHO AMONG
OTHER THINGS WAS INVESTIGATING
THE COMPANY HIS SON SERVED ON
THE BOARD OF, LOOK, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE JUST DESERVE TO KNOW THE
FACTS.
WHAT THEY CAN BE CONFIDENT OF IS
THAT THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS
THAT ALL OF OUR ADMINISTRATION,
THE PRESIDENT'S CONVERSATION,
WERE ALL BASED UPON PROPER
CONSIDERATIONS OF HOW WE SUPPORT
UKRAINE, HOW WE SUPPORT THEIR
EFFORTS TO END AN ERA OF
CORRUPTION IN THEIR GOVERNMENT
AND ADVANCE THE INTEREST OF
THEIR SOVEREIGNTY.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE A RIGHT
TO KNOW WHAT HAPPENED.
THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED IN 2016 AND HAVE A
RIGHT TO KNOW WHAT THE
CIRCUMSTANCES WERE AROUND HAVING
A SITTING VICE PRESIDENT
THREATEN TO WITHHOLD AMERICAN
AID.
LOOK, AGAIN, THE IRONIC THING IS
THAT EVERYTHING THAT OUR CRITICS
IN THE MEDIA ARE LEVELING AT
THIS PRESIDENT FROM THIS PHONE
CALL.
EVERYTHING THE DEMOCRATS ON
CAPITOL HILL ARE RUNNING OFF AND
DESCRIBING COME OF
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN BRAGGED
ABOUT, WHICH IS LIQUID PRO QUOTE
ABOUT, WHICH IS LIQUID PRO QUOT.
>> Sean: WOULDN'T HELP THE
PRESIDENT TO RELEASE A
TRANSCRIPT?
>> Vice President Pence: THAT
WOULD BE A DECISION FOR THE
PRESIDENT TO MAKE.
CONVERSATIONS WITH LEADERS
AROUND THE WORLD THAT ARE
CANDID, THAT ARE OPEN.
FOR LEADERS TO BE CONCERNED IN
THE FUTURE THAT A CONVERSATION
THAT THE PRESIDENT MIGHT MAKE
ITS WAY INTO THE PUBLIC, WOULD
UNDERMINE THE ABILITY OF THE
PRESIDENT TO HAVE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS IN THE FUTURE.
SO ANOTHER PRESIDENT WOULD LIKE
TO DO IT.
I KNOW HE'S LOOKING AT ALL THE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
BUT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE CAN BE
CONFIDENT THAT THE PRESIDENT